in the world of cyberpunk where society
is always on the verge of collapse
the rich get richer and when local
communities are abandoned without any
real social support
gangs sprout up in the vacuum there are
50 plus
gangs mentioned in various cyberpunk
books some are major players while
others exist
just as a punchline like the gang that
roleplays star trek characters for
example
exploring all of them would take forever
so we'll save the older and
weirder stuff for a future video but
let's take a look at the 10
key gangs that will be in the upcoming
video game
let's start with one of the first gangs
we got to see back during cyberpunk
2077's gameplay reveal
the maelstrom gang they are one of night
city's older gangs having been around
since
2020 it actually formed from the ashes
of the metal warriors which was wiped
out by a gang called the inquisitors
naturally the maelstrom's main goal was
to build themselves up
and destroy the inquisitors which they
did by drafting members of
other gangs that held personal beef
against the inquisitors
the trademark look of an old-school
maelstrom member was black leather and
chrome
and a good third of them were
cyberpsychos which is somebody whose
mental state is affected by the use of
too many cybernetic augmentations
despite being dangerous they mostly kept
to smaller crimes like simple robberies
but by 2077 maelstrom has evolved into
one of the most dangerous groups in
night city
their need to improve themselves with
cyber tech has become a core part of
their personalities
developing into an obsession with nearly
all members suffering from cyber
psychosis
the gang is over 1 000 members strong
having set up shop in the industrial
part of the watson district
it mainly deals with the smuggling of
illegal drugs as well as the occasional
hit on corporate transports
where the maelstrom members worship the
tech they use to enhance themselves the
animals
are the polar opposite they are
interested in the raw power of the flesh
and embracing the primal savage nature
of man and beast
instead of electronic tech members boost
themselves with genetic supplements
background muscle implants and something
called ultra testosterone
animals consider themselves the next
dominant step in the evolution of
humanity
often they will pit themselves against
worthy foes in brutal tests of combat
whether it be traditional sporting
competitions or more illegal
altercations against other gangs or the
police
they also model themselves after
supposed animal behavior with the gang
made up of individual packs
run by the strongest member known as the
alpha as such the animals lack any real
home turf and its
3 000 members are spread throughout
night city
shortly after the fourth corporate war
many of its veterans return home to
night city only to be met with
crime-ridden neighborhoods and an
ineffective police force
so a bunch of them got together to form
6th street
a civilian militia that went out into
the streets to bring about the justice
that they felt was missing
and provide protection and training to
local neighborhoods and businesses
members of the 6th street want you to
know that they're just some good old
american boys rocking military uniforms
baseball caps
and a lot of american flags that hit's
different in 2020.
the 6th street of 2077 is still
primarily made up of veterans who think
of themselves as bringers of justice
but that justice has been warped into a
self-serving abuse of power
now its members demand money for
protection smuggle guns and run
chop shops they still patrol their local
turf and primarily pick fights with
other gangs because of this the police
and corporations
tend to leave them alone night city's
largest organized gang
is the valentinos the majority of the
members are of mexican heritage however
they do accept other races and ethnic
groups as such the valentinos bond over
a shared sense of culture and traditions
and celebrate many mexican holidays
the communities of haywood they protect
are fiercely loyal to the valentinos
making the gang nearly untouchable by
the police
the valentinos have been around since
2020 however in such a
vastly different form it's hard to say
if it even shares a connection
outside of the name in 2077 in the old
days the valentinos were a
non-threatening poser gang of men that
engaged in the
art of seduction attempting to pick up
attractive women
off the streets members would then meet
up once every three months to compare
scorecards
basically the valentinos were like if a
group of pickup artists all decided to
start a cyberpunk
street gang today i'm here at venice
beach and it's mommy makeout day
i'm going to find some moms and play a
really quick game
for a really really really quick
another gang that's been around since
2020 is the tiger claws
originally a small group the now 5 000
member organization is a fearsome gang
that models itself after the japanese
yakuza
it likes to put on a face of being a
business with an emphasis on honor and
principles
it's even said to have close ties to the
upper management of the arasaka
corporation
but this attitude really only sticks
with those in high ranking positions
as many of the tiger claws low-ranking
members are violent sadists who abuse
their power
the tiger claws make their home in night
city's japan town and largely make money
from human trafficking and prostitution
you can spot a member of tiger claws by
their neon tattoos
the tiger claws are inadvertently
responsible for the creation of one of
night city's most recent gangs
the mocks elizabeth lizzie borden was a
well-known strip club owner who had a
reputation for treating her workers with
respect
good pay and protection so in 2067 when
one of lizzie's girls was assaulted and
murdered by members of the tiger claws
lizzie took matters into her own hands
killing the men and hanging their bodies
outside her club as a warning
that she was not to be trifled with this
did little to dissuade the tiger claws
however who retaliated in kind by
destroying lizzie's club and killing her
this caused massive protests and rise
throughout night city
and turned elizabeth borden into a
martyr in the movement against gang
violence
looking to keep the spirit of elizabeth
intact her followers
rebuilt her club naming it lizzy's bar
and made it the headquarters of
the mox a gang created to protect sex
workers and sexual minorities
the term sexual minorities isn't defined
specifically but it's probably fair to
assume that this encompasses lgbtq plus
among other groups they are the least
hostile of the major gangs in night city
and primarily stick to their business
so long as you don't mess with them
another small gang that likes to keep to
itself is the voodoo boys
like the valentinos there appears to be
two very different incarnations of the
group
the original voodoo boys of 2020 were a
nihilist terrorist group that would rape
torture and kill its victims seemingly
for no reason
members would use bones as nose piercing
implant feathers on their scalps
and leave chicken blood on doors all
part of some ritual magic theme
here's the thing all of that was just an
act as the majority of the members of
the voodoo boys were all
white boys dressing up in nonsensical
races cosplay and then committing
violent hate crimes for fun
not cool despite bearing the same name
the voodoo boys of 2077 share
no resemblance to the original gang it
is made up entirely of haitian
immigrants living in night city
who banded together after climate change
completely destroyed haiti in 2062
the voodoo boys made its main focus the
protection and support of haitian
refugees
it is an incredibly small and secretive
group and you won't find them on the
streets
instead most voodoo boys are netrunners
and they spend their time hacking
corporate databases
or acting as mercenaries for hire the
last of the in-city gangs is the
scavengers
although it's actually hard to say how
much of it even counts as an organized
group
scavs prey on anyone with nice cyberware
and body augmentations harvesting them
for parts to sell on the black market
scavs have no code or banner to rally
behind and zero regard for the people
they
kill it's unclear how many scavs there
actually are
scouts have no turf operating in small
groups throughout the city with very
little structure
all you should know is that if you see a
scav tag marked on a street corner you
should stay
very far away and finally we have the
two major nomad groups that have set up
shop
outside of night city in the badlands
nomads are roaming caravans of refugees
that have banded together and travel
from city to city
they make up their own societies of
families and clans and have a tight-knit
bond
the first group is the al de caldos one
of the original nomad families to form
back in the 1990s
it was started by juan aldicaldo and his
family when they escaped a war-torn los
angeles and made their way to mexico
city
there's a fair amount of history to the
aldocados that we'll maybe touch on in a
separate video
including their relationship to johnny
silverhand the second nomad group is the
race
it is your quintessential mad max aspire
group of outlaws
members aggressively raid small towns
weaker nomad groups and anyone else who
happens to be in their path
it has a long rivalry with the
aldocaldos and expands numbers by taking
in exiles from other nomad clans
and that was a look at the 10 groups
you'll be facing or perhaps allying with
in cyberpunk 2077
as i mentioned there are a ton of
smaller stranger gangs in the history of
cyberpunk
so look forward to that in an upcoming
video however our next video will be
about the many districts of night city
that these gangs inhabit
if you enjoyed this video and want to
get more involved make sure to check out
our community tab where we run polls
asking
what lore you'd like us to cover such as
last week when you all picked
this very topic thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you